Hello and welcome to another Unreal Engine 5 training course.
Today we're going to be taking a look at Alembic Importing and Live Link.
As an overview of the course, we're going to be taking a look at how to work with Alembic animations in Unreal Engine 5,
including a look at some of the tools in Maya for exporting,
some information on Alembic caches themselves and some of the uses in Unreal Engine 5.
We'll also have an overview of the Live Link feature,
so going over the pipeline and seeing how you can stream your animations into Unreal Engine and see it in your scene,
and just going over the steps to connect it from Maya to Unreal Engine 5.
And along the way we'll take a look at some Blender tools, we'll understand a bit about the Datasmith,
and we'll see how to get your Alembic cache animations playing in your scene using some of the sequencer tools.